c
[Musique]
elle date du 15ème siècle la ferme de
bus loyer à magny les hameaux va
accueillir en octobre prochain la
ferme-école graines d'avenir une école
de production qui va former au métier de
maraîcher primeur pour en parler nous
sommes avec bruno et marc le co
fondateur de cette école bonjour bonjour
nicolas
alors en quoi consistent les formations
vous allez proposer à partir du mois
d'octobre alors nous avions nous allons
associer agro écologie et enseignement
innovants pour former des jeunes aux
métiers maraîchers primeur donc à la
production la transformation et la vente
de fruits et légumes frais des
formations destinées à quel type de
profil alors on s'adresse à des jeunes
dès 15 ans qui voudrait trouver une voie
complémentaire entre le lycée
professionnel ou parfois ils trouvent
que c'est trop d'écoles pas assez de
vécu du métier et le cfa où ils n'ont
parfois pas la maturité pour se
retrouver seul dans un monde d'adultes
c'est une formation qui donne à accepter
le diplôme du coup à la fin alors à deux
diplômes professionnels d'état sur trois
ans on va les former au sein des
primeurs qui est un diplôme qui existe
depuis 2018 qui reconnaît le savoir
faire spécifique de la vente de fruits
et légumes frais d'ailleurs le rayon et
au titre professionnel d'ouvriers de
production horticole de la graine
jusqu'à la plante et sa
commercialisation
pourquoi vous êtes lancés dans cette
aventure
pourquoi on s'est lancé dans cette
aventure la volonté de
d'avoir un impact sur les enjeux
alimentaires de notre territoire que ce
soit agriculture locale les circuits
courts mais aussi la volonté de
travailler sur l'insertion des jeunes la
lutte contre le décrochage de scolaires
et la lutte contre le chômage des jeunes
je disais au début de cette émission
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ses 21 % de
terres agricoles c'est 32 exploitation
installés sur le territoire c'est aussi
rendre attractif ces métiers peut-être
que s'il ya des besoins aussi par
rapport à ces acteurs de l'agriculture
locale alors une école de production
c'est un écosystème entre les
territoires les jeunes et les
entreprises les territoires je voulais
dit lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
lutte contre le chômage des jeunes les
jeunes leur proposer une troisième voie
et les entreprises c'est mettre sur le
marché des jeunes rapidement
opérationnel et former au métier
d'ailleurs nous allons commercialiser
aussi nos produits c'est à dire que les
jeunes vont pratiquer le métier ils vont
répondre à des vraies commandes vrais
clients aux conditions du marché et donc
l'ours qui vont intégrer une entreprise
ils auront déjà sept cette pratique
merci bruno ai marre je rappelle que
vous êtes le co fondateur de la ferme
école graines d'avenir
et puis maintenant on va aller découvrir
justement le contenu des formations
c'est ça oui tout à fait on va les
rejoindre donatien qui est notre maître
professionnels
maraîcher et qui aujourd'hui travaillent
à mettre en exploitation la ferme pour
accueillir nos élèves en octobre il est
d'ailleurs en train de planter les choux
c'est parti à longvic alors du coup ça
ce sont des choux c'est ça oui ce sont
des choux et cette fois ce sont des
choux 2001 des choux frisés d'accord
alors le principe là ça va être nous ce
qu'on a on a préparé ce qu'on appelle un
match c'est à dire une protection
végétale au dessus du sol pour protéger
le sol et retenir l'humidité les rayons
du soleil tape moins le sol et
l'humidité rap bien reste bien le sol et
en plus c'est de la matière organique ou
ça va nourrir le sol et le principe ça
va être de traverser ce match comme
quand on traverse la paille et le broyat
on va chercher la terre le broyat c'est
la terre noire c'est ça exactement on
est parti la chercher c'est tout ce que
les gens jettent en déchetterie d'accord
voilà on cherche bien cette zone là et
ensuite on va enfoncer le plan à
l'intérieur voilà et on referme la terre
il renferme bien le must pour cueillir
uniquement le chou qui sortent de notre
couvert d'accords voilà et on avance
quand c'est petit à petit toujours en
quinconce donc je vais comme le disait
bruno et marin l'idée c'est aussi de
pratiquer sa voilà ce qui est important
avec les écoles de production c'est le
faire pour apprendre c'est à dire au
lieu de leur dire on fait comme si on
fait comme ça on va directement sur le
terrain est alors montre comment ça se
passe directement la production mais
justement on va se retrouver tout à
l'heure devant le clan de chou et puis
pour nous expliquer le contenu de ces
formations acquis en attendant on va
continuer à planter les choux
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
finalement là vous êtes en train de
préparer les parcelles pour la formation
au mois d'octobre
c'est ça alors on est actuellement en
train de préparer des parcelles qui vont
servir à récolter et à récolter des
choux pour l'hiver parce que les élèves
ont bien soit à partir d'octobre et on a
planté tous les légumes de conservation
qui vont pouvoir durer tout l'automne et
tout l'hiver pour que les élèves
puissent récolter des choux pendant la
formation
alors concrètement qu'est ce que vous
aller enseigner à ses élèves
on va enseigner toutes les tâches
pratiques qui va y avoir en maraîchage
c'est-à-dire semer la graine
l'entretenir s'occuper de l'arrosage la
plantation savoir connaître une mauvaise
herbe savoir reconnaître une lap la
plante savoir reconnaître les maladies
pouvoir utiliser les produits qui vont
avec où les traitements qu'on utilise en
agriculture biologique et après récoltés
et mettre en forme les légumes pour
ensuite les vendre à savez de quoi une
semaine type à la ferme école de graines
d'avenir à magny les hameaux
la semaine type ça va être le lundi
matin un petit peu d'exercice en ce
moment chauffe après le week-end un peu
difficile on regarde un peu l'état des
parcelles ont fait le point ensemble de
tout ce qui va se passer pendant la
semaine on regarde les gros chantiers
des petits chantiers ont réparti les
tâches en fonction des différents
ateliers ceux qui vont gérer l'arrosage
ceux qui vont gérer la plantation ceux
qui vont gérer la suivi des cultures les
récoltes etc et ensuite on va
directement sur le terrain planter
récolter désherber faire tout l'ensemble
des tâches comme un effet habituellement
c'est combien d'heures par semaine de
formation normand de ses 35 heures sur
les écoles de production il faut savoir
les écoles de production ses 35 heures
avec deux tiers de t&e de pratiques
pardon et un tiers de théorique c'est à
dire qu'ils vont passer deux tiers du
temps vraiment sur le terrain soit
culture et les légumes soient les vendre
et ensuite un tir de théorique où on va
leur apprendre les matières générales
mathématiques français anglais et c'est
toujours lié avec le maraîchage par
exemple on va d'abord planter des choux
là on regarde le nombre de densité et
c'est ensuite le professeur de
mathématiques qui va venir voir qui va
demander aux élèves comment ça se fait
que vous avez réussi à planter les choux
quelle densité vous avez utilisé ils du
coup la plantation de choux va servir un
support pour pouvoir faire de
l'enseignement théorique
combien d'élèves vont être accueillis à
partir à partir d'octobre ce serait une
promo de 12 élèves qui va y avoir
vous les avez déjà on en a eu une bonne
partie mais on va se réserver un petit
peu pour la fin de l'été étant donné
qu'il ya une grosse partie de
recrutement qui suit en septembre on
laisse encore des places libres
donc on peut toujours s'inscrire alors
sur le site internet de la ferme-école
exactement vous nous contactez on vous
envoie
goût rencontre on vous envoie ensuite un
formulaire d'inscription est on avec le
plaisir vous accueille en octobre et
toutes les informations sont à retrouver
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas d'écran merci et donatien merci à
vous de venir rappelle que vous êtes
remettre professionnels le maraîcher
voilà merci à vous bonne journée